- Lemme know if you've ever
been in this situation.
You're sitting down writing something,
and you've been struggling for hours
trying to find the right words.
It's super painful and frustrating,
and no good ideas are coming to your head.
But all of a sudden, something hits you.
The right words magically
seem to just come to you.
It's like you've been mining
in a cold, dark cave for days,
and you finally struck gold.
Or maybe you're playing
around on the piano
trying to improvise something,
and you're not really coming
up with anything good.
But then all of a sudden
you try something new,
and you somehow pull off
a brilliant new melody.
It's like genius struck
for a brief moment,
and then faded from existence.
Moments like these seem to
fall upon us kind of randomly
and without warning.
While we're in them, it's almost euphoric.
Things kind of click together
and start making sense,
like the pieces to a giant complex puzzle
are starting to snap themselves together.
But most of the time, this
just isn't how things go.
Practicing an instrument is
usually tedious and boring.
Writing is difficult.
But as we're trudging
through these activities,
we remember those brief
bouts of brilliance
and we hope that this time,
when we're participating in our craft,
it can be like that one time
when things just clicked.
Although they may seem like it,
these little flashes of brilliance
aren't just random and nonsensical.
They are a window, through
which we can catch a glimpse
of our potential.
It's like a little preview of the power
which we all possess inside of us.
A power that makes this elusive state
of brilliance and creativity
into a consistent and replicable reality.
And if we're able to
fully develop this power,
it can give us a greater
command over ourselves,
over others, and over the world around us.
This power is called mastery.
Now when most people
think of the word mastery,
they think of somebody who's
really good at something.
Beethoven was a master
composer and musician.
And most people would
say that Martin Scorsese
is a master filmmaker.
But mastery is a lot more
than just being really good at something.
Because the master has such
a thorough understanding
of his craft, that it becomes
like an extension of himself.
It becomes a language they can use
to influence and inspire other people
in a way that seems almost magical.
A masterpiece of literature
can bring us to tears of joy
or tears of bitter sadness.
And a master painting
can cause us to reflect
on the fleeting nature of time,
or the nature of our very existence.
It's as if the master,
through their expertise,
has access to something
like the heart of life.
But a lot of people disqualify themselves
from ever achieving mastery
in whatever their craft is.
You know, if they're a
normal person like you or me,
we tend to thing that we're
incapable of achieving mastery
like some of the greats before us.
We may be tempted to think that mastery
is reserved for the genius
or the child prodigy.
But the truth is mastery is something
that already exists inside you,
and it's up to you to develop it.
So how does one go about
developing their mastery?
Well you may have heard
that it takes 10,000 hours
of practice to become
a master at something.
And this is kind of true.
You do need an insane amount of practice
at your given craft in
order to achieve mastery.
But it isn't just a numbers game.
You're probably never going
to put in that amount of time
practicing a craft if you
don't actually enjoy it.
Which is why the first step of mastery
is to discover your calling.
Everyone who has ever lived
has at least one thing
that sets their imagination on fire.
Something we feel naturally
drawn towards or fascinated by.
Whether that's constructing something,
or solving a problem, or
playing an instrument,
because of your unique brain,
you have certain things
you really dislike doing
and certain things that you
really have a preference for.
So really reflect on your life
and figure out where your passions lie.
If you really like doing something
and you feel an importance while doing it,
then that's an indication
that you can potentially
become a master in this thing.
But passion alone won't get you far.
The second step on the road to mastery
is to eliminate the ego.
Realize that you know absolutely nothing,
and become a blank canvas.
You need to seek every opportunity to grow
and view everything as a
potential learning experience.
Approach your craft with
a ruthless objectivity.
Don't identify as being good
or talented at anything.
Because that puts a barrier in the way
of viewing your work objectively,
and being critical about it.
A good example of me not doing this
was when I was in a filmmaking class.
And I always carried
around this sense of pride
about my filmmaking ability.
I was usually the best
filmmaker in a room.
But I'm usually in a room
where nobody makes films,
so that's pretty easy.
My now good friend Jared also made films.
Hey Jared, you're gonna
be in my video, okay?
- Okay, right now?
- Before I knew him really well,
he would present his work to the class,
and it was pretty good.
And I would feel threatened by this,
because I'm supposed
to be a good filmmaker.
And for some reason, his work being good
was a threat to that?
It doesn't make any sense.
But that's because the ego is involved.
You need to eliminate the need
to be the best artist in the room,
or the best at your craft,
or the best athlete.
Because when you're trying
to learn as much as possible,
none of that matters.
If you can eliminate the ego,
then you can view the work of your peers,
and figure out what they're
doing better than you are.
And then you can apply
that to your own work.
It also allows you to
look at your own work
with a ruthless objectivity as well,
and scrutinize it more.
This video's pretty trash.
Find out where your weak spots are,
and try to make them strengths.
None of this is possible
if you have a giant ego,
and identify as a master long
before you've earned that title.
Step Number Three on the road to mastery
is to learn to embrace tedium.
When you first approach a craft,
you approach it as an apprentice.
Practicing your craft, for the most part,
is going to be tedious.
It's not going to be very exciting.
Applying new techniques and trying
to stretch your boundaries is
usually really uncomfortable,
boring, and not very exciting.
Why does that look so bad?
But if you learn to
embrace the tedious nature
of practicing your craft day after day,
you'll eventually reach a
point of accelerated return.
You start to become a practitioner.
And the practitioner understands
the complex relationships
between each component of their craft.
They start to get a view
of the bigger picture.
They can really engage with their craft
in a more creative way.
Once you reach this stage in the game,
practicing becomes a lot less
tedious, and more enjoyable.
You can start to have some fun with it.
But the road doesn't end there.
You still need to propel
yourself into mastery.
You still need to find
that deeper understanding.
And one of the most effective
ways you can do this
is move on to Step Number Four,
which is absorb the master's power.
Since you've become a practitioner,
you can use your competency in your craft
as sort of a proof that
you take it seriously,
and you're willing to learn.
You can then take this proof to somebody
who's much better than you at your craft,
and work under them.
It's crucial that you find somebody
who's much better than you at what you do,
and learn from them,
so that you don't have
to reinvent the wheel.
Your work can also be
scrutinized by somebody
who has the authority to scrutinize it.
By learning from a master,
you can then view your own
work through their eyes,
and try to work on things
that they would want you to work on.
And working alongside a
master collaboratively
is a great way to become one yourself.
But if you're unwilling to
take this path towards mastery,
then this creative power inside
you will remain undeveloped.
It will lie dormant.
It'll occasionally reveal itself
in these little glimmers
of temporary brilliance,
begging to be fully realized.
(birds tweeting)
In case it wasn't already clear,
this entire video was based
off of the book, "Mastery",
by Robert Greene.
And it's one of my favorite
books I've read this year.
And I'd highly recommend checking out
the audiobook version of "Mastery",
using today's video sponsor Audible,
because that's exactly
how I read the book.
I really like it when
Audible sponsors my videos,
because they're super easy to recommend.
I probably listen to more audiobooks
than I read physical books nowadays.
Audiobooks are great for
listening to good literature
when you're on the go,
if you're working out,
going for a run.
If you're doing something monotonous
that doesn't take much thought,
you might as well be expanding
your mind in the process.
Not only does Audible
have the largest selection
of audiobooks on the entire Internet,
but every single month,
you can download one audiobook for free,
regardless of cost, as well
as two Audible originals.
So to sign up for your free 30 day trial,
click the link in the description.
Visit audible.com/betterideas,
or text "betterideas" to 500-500.
And one of my favorite things
about Audible (chuckles)
what am I don't with my hands?
If you cancel your subscription,
you still keep your
entire library of books.
Once again, click the
link in the description
or text "betterideas" to 500-500
to start your free 30 day trial,
and have a good time.
So, this video took me
a long time to make,
mostly because it just took
me a long time to write.
I wrote probably, 8000
words about "Mastery"
because it's such a rich book.
But I wrote a lot of things,
and they weren't necessarily all connected
in this nice through line.
So it was really hard for
me to try to figure out
how to distill such a rich
book, packed with information,
into a under 10 minute video.
But hopefully you can find
something useful out of it.
But if you liked this video,
make sure to hit "like",
because when you hit "like",
the algorithm does fancy things,
and it helps my face show
up in, on your home page.
And it really helps spread the channel.
If you're lurking here,
consider subscribing
and hitting the bell icon
so that you don't miss future videos.
I'm having Q and A really
soon on my second channel.
I'll put the link in
the description to that.
Should be a lot of fun.
Other than that, that's all for today.
Thanks a lot for watching,
and we'll catch you in the next video.
(gentle music)